et avant l'arrivée du vaccin qui ne sera
pas obligatoire les français devront
encore se discipliner et respecter les
mesures sanitaires et ce pendant de
longs mois
mais le déconfinement est en marche
c'est ce qu'a annoncé emmanuel macron
hier soir avec plusieurs paliers
première étape le 28 novembre les
commerces non essentiels pourront
rouvrir mais jusqu'à 21 heures seulement
alors comment cette annonce a été reçue
par les principaux concernés
réponse avec romain delville et lucas
chopin taux de bon matin sabrina et
aurélie sont venus remplir les
rayonnages de vêtements dans leur
magasin de la rue des halles à partir de
samedi
cette boutique de plus de 100 mètres
carrés pourra accueillir dix personnes
en est ravi c'est pas trop tôt c'est
notre plus grosse période donc on
n'attend qu'une chose c'est que les
clients soient au rendez vous samedi et
les autres jours bien sûr autre
configuration mais même enthousiasme
pour anne marie et son équipe
les tenues et accessoires commander par
internet sont prêts à être récupérés
pour l'accueil de la clientèle
la responsable fera comme au premier
déconfinement quatre personnes et un
sens de circulation dans les 36 m² si on
a une personne qui a plusieurs articles
la cabine d'essayage
c'est vrai qu'on peut pas lui bien
dépêchez vous madame ya du monde quatre
en dehors où il ya des gens qui vont pas
attendre dehors que la personne sauf
donc ils vont aller ailleurs peut-être
pour ce coiffeur
l'annnonce de la réouverture des salles
on est non seulement une bonne nouvelle
mais aussi une bonne surprise
il reste une difficulté et pas des
moindres le respect des huit mètres
carrés par personne
ici on a la chance de pouvoir avoir un
local pour vraiment appliquer le décret
des huit mètres carrés
je vous cache pas que ça va être assez
difficile ça c'est sûr et je pense que
pour mes autres collaborateurs ça c'est
pareil maintenant bon voilà on attend
que le décret change si on pouvait
repasser éventuellement sur la barre des
4 mètres carrés économiquement pour la
santé de nos entreprises tout ça ça
serait quand même beaucoup plus facile à
gérer
autre éclaircie pour les commerçants la
mairie de tours s'apprête à autoriser
l'ouverture des boutiques les quatre
dimanches avant noël
et ça commence dès dimanche